two weeks ago today
uh Brent had congested heart failure and
a stroke uh he's only 23. NeNe Leakes
close to tears as she confirms her son
Brent's shocking Health scare he's
really young for something like that to
happen to him having my son was probably
the best thing that ever happened to me
because he changed my life the former
Bravo star sharing new details about the
23 year old's unexpected issues on
Instagram essentially calling it a
medical mystery they have run a number
of tests on him to see
what could have possibly made this
happen to him and uh we are still
trying to figure out because if we knew
the cause obviously they could treat the
cause
um it was very scary
um
um I I don't even want to go into
details uh what happened and
how I found out and what condition he
was in
um obviously a stroke is a very serious
thing and so
um he's struggling you know with
speaking as they try and figure out what
went wrong Nene wonders if her own past
might be a factor here if you remember
some years ago I had blood clots in my
lungs and we could not figure out where
it came from I bet you the first day
when you're having that pain that was
when a little bit of clot flew up there
okay and then the next day when you had
more discovered more clotted flown up
from your leg so they're thinking that
maybe Brent was born with some sort of
disease or or something with his heart
since he was a kid and uh it just never
showed up until now I'm just I'm baffled
I
Battlefield
it's a lot Brent landed in the hospital
just a little over a year after the loss
of his dad Nene's late husband to Greg
that's about the Lord we come to you
right now with heavy hearts but right
now we especially praying over Greg
right now as he's battled this thing
that they call cancer Greg died in
September of last year after battling
colon cancer he and Nene were together
for 25 years my circle is really okay
with me bringing up Greg or talking
about Greg so many of us know him
because he was around for so long and
you can't just forget about somebody
like that after 25 years so it's highs
and lows and you know grieving is hard
I've never had anybody to die that close
to me that was a really it was a trying
time and Mimi thinks Brent's current
problems could also be related to his
father one of the things I do know great
Brent was very stressed out in the month
of September because that was the one
year anniversary for the passing of his
dad I was very close to his dad and he's
been super stressed out over it still
Nene's staying positive I'm in a good
place she's turning to her faith and
appreciates the support her family is
getting during this difficult time I
will just
yeah you know just keep praying that we
find the cause because once we find the
cause we're able to treat the cause and
obviously that's what we want to do we
do have a lot of support a lot of people
that are asking but we could use all the
support we can get Brent has a lot of
great bonus dance that are surrounding
him right now and uh so we thank you
guys thank you
[Music]
foreign